Salam alaikum how you guys doing welcome
back to the Deen show and I'm with the
founder of Ali Hooda Maroof
how are you brother
[Music]
alaikum Salaam I forgot how you been Oh
busy busy well it's guilty I hope it
will be something for the slow ones and
you're you're coming in from Denmark
right yes
many parents fall in that pit fall the
trap and kids are running around you
know the lot of times the mothers have
such a mate they're the engineers of the
house you know the homemakers and
sometimes you know you just want to get
a peace of mind and you just put the
kids down and you might find something
that you think is innocent and little lo
and behold you know the kids are
spending hours and in those hours just
keep adding up and it's almost like you
know like a an education all around just
if you add up all the amount of time and
a true story and the other day I was um
you know I looked up and I saw one of
these cartoons I just stopped for for a
minute to see like what what what's this
all about because we know that there's
there's messages in many of these and
one of them that I I noticed this is a
real situation I'm watching and I saw
the that it was like some worm some you
know it looks cute and funny and whatnot
and then the the girl in the cartoon the
girl worm she got mad and she said she
said something along the lines of you
better not upset me or I'm not going to
let it rain and then the other person
the other cartoon character said well
what are you talking about for the rain
something like that but we know as
Muslims these things might come off
innocent but no we know that though the
Creator that heavens and earth Allah
he's the one that sends down the rain so
again these are the subtle but
subliminal you could say messages that
are being sent that's just one example
out of many with
many of the the dating and you know from
kissing violence so I think this work
that you're doing is extremely important
to substitute where you can rest assured
that okay if I leave my kids to watch
some cartoons that they're not going to
be letting in toxic poison into their
little minds
I mean if it's funny you mention this
tip so I mean let's episode as I said
maybe they're subliminal message right
but according to the BBC and in Guardian
recently wrote an article and some of
these YouTube videos actually it's not
just subliminal it's like for example
you may find a normal for example pepper
pepper cake or some other normal movie
cartoons right or Hello Kitty you think
or even the Nike Mouse you think you're
watching them but in the end since
probably copyright or something be
changed to widen very very unpredictable
things even scary for adults and it's
been reported by BBC and the Guardian
which really scares is apparent but
because my story why I'm doing this is I
hope that lesson with the three kids and
they've been driven grown in the West
and you know since you also in the West
you know you're not the issues for the
kids going of addresses we always
struggle right what do you learn they're
always learning constantly learning from
our learning from the society what the
emergence our responsibilities what we
teach them and I wasn't really happy
what I could find on YouTube or Netflix
and some of them are fine so they're
okay just just neutral right but some of
them may not be okay but this is
reacting I mean this is not good enough
we should do something if you only want
to change the nation we should change
their education what you learn
especially starting with the young kids
so instead we thought that it's okay
is it a possibility if you create a
platform where kids not only just just
sit you just learn but also entertain
and they just keep it at the same time
at the back end instead of being empty a
message or something very subliminal
negative a message can we put positive
the core values teachings of Islam and
it seems it seems that it is possible
the reason we can do that is
this is you said we just son and if you
don't calm it's like a similar to
Netflix right a video on the mastering
platform from some kids the producers
I'm not even producing video but I work
at intrapreneurs understand the
technology behind it also understand
some marketing so what we did we create
a platform and now we are instead of we
create ourselves what we are doing is we
are working together with some a TV
channels I just mentioned from UK I'm
hoping they're already working with some
channel which wasn't even email channel
I hope only very good amount of videos
from some kids and cartoons which is
already approved which is loved by UK
and never want to bring this the same
experience because there were some kids
in u.s. so the most gives in Malaysia or
Indonesia or everywhere wherever you
can't for the kind of access to this
quality education and the lips part of
producers are working or they are more
independent producers most of them are
actually from Malaysia they have very
good content they have very good we
understand it very seriously it actually
is a matter of fact we're even launching
the Malaysian version of the site
probably sometime this month so there a
huge demand out there so that's going to
be now in different how do you how is it
is it primarily in English yes starting
this month won't be adding the Malaysian
language yeah so it's extremely
important because these are the little
minds they're soaking up everything like
sponges and an hour here sometimes it's
like 3-4 hours maybe even your
babysitter so now you have a babysitter
and the babysitter is on some other
level there or he's doing some other
thing and he said put the kid down and
now that kid is watching maybe Bart
Simpson and I don't know now or the
what's that some of these kind of out of
tune but there's many of these cartoons
the one you mentioned mention in the BBC
article that was that a little pig or
the piggy or something like that and
they were doing many violent violent
acts and now you wonder why your kids
start acting violent right because
they're they're getting educated on
violence look at the world we say we
expand think they'll learn at school
kids earn I mean even as humans we are
learning all the time if you were wrong
it's about what we we are what we
consume right it's like you are what you
eat you also want to consume what you
put your mind to it
imagine if you put our kids instead of
this kind of things but the result won't
be just a matter of fact we will see
that the similar something it's just
just copy what they see and
unfortunately that's that's the case I
mean let me give an example since we
just I mean world we did write liquid ah
it's awesome mainly for my kids is wrong
so what we what the way we use it is we
try to minimize at home but will be of
commuting because I said bribe them for
their proper schooling back it's like a
half an hour now
I give them sometimes these videos and I
heard you know just just a bit a month I
can I keep amazed how much they learn
and they already I mean do you know the
best they are going is with the
engagement you learn the names of the
prophets cuz there is something there
waste because one thing we have to
understand the reason the reason the
kids watch this thing for their
entertainment right so the videos and
how it's done the story is entertaining
and we understand one thing we should
not ignore that which is a good thing
but there keeps you the best message
right instead of we shut out ourself
from this technology which is the wrong
room what we should do I believe it is
we should replace the message with a
good one
and give the new technology kids and our
kids will learn they would love learning
people Bob as much they enjoy me imagine
like imagine a teacher that she sees the
kids today to sell them and is NASA
instead we can learn it by games and
especially by the videos and which one
is much more effective of course the
second one because they can watch
anytime they came to the enjoyment and I
heard it about just watching this
cartoons and you can see that what kids
are learning and and we watched we want
the same thing to the drama remaining
meaning from some kids around the world
they have this curiosity about knowledge
right we're talking
but inshallah if things so successful
you know what what introduces imagine we
have so many emission scholars with some
science in the past this is amazing
stuff right imagine it could bring their
stories back right the image we said
okay imagine this the this color the
quality for example he kind of leaves
the kind of algebra or who's founded
with the university teacher history our
kids we also not only just doing them
but good thing also increase your
information including say wow our
ancestors did that but today when we
look at the innovation look always look
at the West we kind of look at the
supermarket and actually in reality it's
not we just have to remember the past
what we can do and inspire the future
generation and you may never know what
since you have gone on this journey of
putting all this together
have you seen and you've seen much of
the content do you think that we're way
behind in this technology in this field
in this in the animations and the
cartoons and this area in and in kids
entertainment do you feel that we're we
don't have enough resources that don't
my at large has not invested enough in
this that's the funny part
we started don't do that yeah that's war
we don't have enough content only for
that problem and you know we we reverse
when people complain we listen anyway
because of people think but the question
is before we started we thought okay the
content could be a problem it is still a
problem but one thing we began to see is
in the series a hundred as I said we
work with TV channels that do produce
content they give us to us and it's a
currency that's one thing other thing is
what we are discovering is especially in
Malaysia wants to hit what really
important is there are so many quality
that the cartoons in three
with the same ethics like Islamic core
values the hippies
they're so mean yeah we are we are not
seizing almost in one every week you
know try to get them on work and so
exactly like a 3-4 months ago I would
say yeah it's a very problem but now I
can see a hundred net there are so many
interesting properties coming out
I believe we may not be at the same like
Walt Disney on all the big guys yeah but
trust me we have to tell them we have
the women even get the resources if it's
a matter of just starting baby steps if
you create a platform if you enable the
producers you know give them enough
motivation by financing them and we
don't have any challenges so many good
talent can get into use so I'm very very
optimistic in genre we have we have the
content already but if you had yeah and
going back to protecting that treasure
that you mana the trust that the creator
of the heavens and earth Allah has given
every parent and you mentioned the Walt
Disney and most of these young kids that
the kids have attached their heart to I
miss is a fact people can go look it up
these young actors at a young age the
Miley Cyrus's most of them they started
off in the Walt Disney and what happened
is the kids they get attached to them
and most of them they grow up to turn to
drugs you know alcohol and unfortunately
they they go down a road of destruction
and now if the kids their heart attaches
to them as a youth naturally they're
gonna also grow to like them as adults
so cutting this off you know from how
again many parents naive they don't they
you just you look at like I said I was
looking at the cartoon and it looked so
innocent but you have to sit there
literally through the whole thing to
kind of it could be 80 percent 95 99
percent is a-okay 90 95 percent but it's
just a few percent that percentage
yeah the message that's being sent next
to you know it's a message here message
dare a seed here seed there and next
thing you know you're like where my kids
getting this but that's the thing now
you open another door you replace it you
don't just say oh this is you know Haram
that's it we can't do it
no replace it with content that is
suitable and sustainable for their minds
to growing to learn and most of it just
wastes the time there is no there are
there are some some you know we look for
material that's helping them with with
math and scientists good things as
produced but a lot of is just
entertainment and things that don't
really you know it's a lot of waste
wasting of time but many of these how's
the content that you've that you got
you've put together its how what when
the kids the what are they getting when
they come to Ali who did we have a
screening right so okay what the kids
are learning
I mean is it set and if you don't wanna
entertainment we don't want to do any
either of those we don't want to be just
entertainment or education so if you do
just entertainment as youth it will be
empty when you think path prove all the
stuff but there's nothing substance to
learn but at the same time if you do
just education people get born if you
just stick certificate born I think the
fine balance is somebody in the middle
and stocks or something always in the
middle right so unique education
interesting in ask kids don't kind of
realized their learning and they walked
with joy and good morning it's but I
hope you know we have produces well
publishers wonderful aligned with our
mission and that's that's what we're
producing we are really happy to do get
them on board and and that's what we are
after we want to educate entertain the
same time so kids don't get bored and
keep learning so much I mean it's every
job you have for example it's based on
give me one example what I mean scope
for example misery bunch this is a show
from UK so there are a couple of animals
Poppins they are learning about Omar
right
Oman is on but she so what does it mean
I didn't see sure we have installed
brainy burns
it shows this came to a different end
for example how to say you see that it
not be specifically in the context other
one is how to help their parents or how
to pay Leda
so everything this emotion of the
spiritual emotional intellectual trader
and all the server about elements
elements it's a very very pretty show
it's not very enjoyable to watch and
come on kids love because we be here but
there are many many kids out there among
it because we can see the front of set
this if you come and come back and keep
watching them sometimes the kids like it
we keep watching it and watch it watch
it sometimes pigeon songs like hundreds
of things but who did that and now in my
kids they just sometimes sing the is
back that's our song or the main gist of
profits instead of singing twinkle
twinkle little star so you just decide
right what I teach me the kids repeat
whatever they want they can repeat the
process names you can play five profits
for example mission Quran they can learn
it I mean and that was the problem that
that we were having is that many parents
have is that let's say for instance my
kids they would end up going through
there's a really I don't know if you you
got hooked up with Zakir with you you
guys have rocky on there we went so then
we are talking to them just wanted to
give an example for instance that's one
of the cartoons that's out there with a
positive message so you have Zaki Adams
world and you buy all these DVDs and
then now the kids watch it but then you
really you thought oh I got enough form
no they get bored quick so they finish
all that and then maybe they watch it
two three more times but that's it and
you're stuck but here but here you it's
kind of setup like the you compared to
the the kids Netflix so now you have
enough contact to keep their little
brain stimulated
the content interesting enough so keep
kids keep watching them right that's
very important is that and quality of
the complex quantity of the content
that's what we eat regular yeah yeah
muscle majority of publishers but we're
not publisher we work with any other
publisher would bring all the content
out there and the mystic left a little
pair of the kids decide which one is
better which one is good it's also it's
also kind of runs by ages customers of
different categories mm-hmm yeah because
you can be on YouTube and that's that's
a powerful platform now and let's say
you found a channel but next thing you
know the kids end up on another channel
or you didn't feel ya there's no really
control and next thing you know they're
addicted to something that's poison
that's toxic for their little brains
again the reason why we are doing this
right because many parents they say hey
woohoo that's your charge cycle on
YouTube but what the understand
understand is you should be some free
they think it's free
yes you don't pay it but you pay with
your attention right you people the kids
attention are you okay to exclude your
kids so those little messages and this
age I'm gonna do that myself
it said I mean it says I would just pay
the small fee a month and so I know they
are safe they're not wandering around
somewhere which I have no control what
they want right and that's what I would
prefer so it's not nothing is free in
this world
everyone kind of sooner yeah it comes at
a cost I mean some of these it's really
you have people if you look at the route
who is in some of these programs the
mastermind behind putting everything
together you know when Shaitaan comes he
doesn't you know as the story goes he's
not gonna come and just you know show
himself he can come like you know the
the the wolf in sheep's clothing so you
don't know who's behind this series of
of kids cartoons but then when you go
down that rabbit hole and you look and
you
see this person is part of some satanic
cult or just you know an extreme case or
this person has you know these
worldviews and then they need to push it
right so they'll push it this doesn't
happen in every in all cases but you
have many a great majority where now
it's about the bottom-line money and
then this person has their worldview and
there's maybe sick philosophies and now
and now they want to push this on to
kids it's a reality message right so the
middle and it's up to us as a parents we
are the ones who are responsible do you
want our kids watch and we should be the
Guardians
sure there's something safe I've seen
I've seen these little kids you know
these in these cartoons
starting off having boy you know in
relationships and whatnot nothing to do
with marriage right as opposed the
contrast you know let's say they're
watching something at the alley hooda
and now of course this is something
needs to be talked about men and women
relationships in marriage and a
wholesome way that's pleasing to the
Creator to Allah but now over here you
know there's no restrictions no
guidelines so now the the young kids are
watching you know the little mermaids
kissing and it seems innocent so I just
know but that stuff that toxic poor
that's gonna end up maturing in their
brain and that's they're gonna end up
following these things and then no
wonder kids that's at a young age in the
in the in the schools they're they're
dating they're literally kids are having
boyfriend and girlfriends at ages like
eight nine ten years old this is a
reality and many parents are believe to
this fact
Wow yeah I don't know how it is there
but here it's a real it's a reality kids
at a young age at eight nine ten in many
of these public schools there you know
already experimenting and where are they
getting this many of these things are
coming from you know either at home the
the T the the cartoons the T the
programs the things that are programming
them do it they're the data they're
collecting yeah yeah
so how can how can people start you have
a free trial going on people can touch
the waters yes yes actually what we was
thinking is what we go to do is if
someone we gotta create a sister like
kind of promo code for your beach
viewers probably it will be the caddies
show so we should you are on the CEO or
how do you share your message so when
people click you will share they will
see this better and don't get they won't
get 50 50 percent it's time to the first
so yeah first we get free trial for 7
days after that we pay only 50 percent
but even after that we want to keep the
price as small as possible I like I
think it's like 7 or 8 dollars a month
from $8 a month it's like almost like 1
or 2 years maximum but you should look
at we use so much clothes and food to
our kids we have all that we believe in
this and you know it is a small amount
with your food so what I think that's
why I believe it's a fair price and the
shows keep growing in the number of and
you can watch
unlike elastic dollars inside the family
you can have as many devices as you can
there's no limit and we always serve H
the highest quality whatever it is
available and you can watch as many
times as you want if you have you've
know many kids they have Mohamed sure
there's more kids don't have to worry
about just like one come one one you
know access that's it
because your kids or five kids it's up
to you I think definitely that's a great
investment invest now and these this is
one piece of the puzzle otherwise once
the ship sails that's it right so thank
you very much and may God Almighty Allah
bless this endeavor of yours and
continue put butter in it thank you so
much thank you very much Jacque Lahaina
and thank you guys for tuning in you
heard here heard it here the Ali the Ali
Hooda and we'll send out a special link
coming out just for you guys make sure
check it out see how you like it and
we'll see you next time inshallah until
then peace be with you Sonic